all right well I'm really happy to see
so many of you made it back from lunch
it's great great to have you here and
it's wonderful to have Lydia Del Rio
here talking about quantum
thermodynamics area I'm really
passionate about them sure we'll get to
hear a lot more from her thank you okay
thank you thank you very much all of you
so good to see so many familiar faces
and thank you to the organizers for
inviting me to give this tutorial since
there are already a few talks about
thermodynamics in at this conference
which I will announce at the end this
would be a very broaden and in a way a
bit superficial tutorial just to give
you kind of an overview of the field for
those of you who are computer scientists
or mathematicians or the kind of
physicists that I was before starting to
work on thermodynamics so it's just to
give you more of an idea of what quantum
thermodynamics is and how we're
approaching it okay so let's just start
with a small introduction why why should
we study quantum thermodynamics why's is
interesting so there are three different
perspectives in my opinion so on one
hand you have the philosopher so these
are people like me wonder likewise
thermodynamics such an effective theory
is it is it like is it just an emergency
Rhee or can we can you have some
axiomatic formulation something like
information driven approach to
thermodynamics well what is really the
essence of this theory then we can have
someone who is an explorer who has
studied thermodynamics of large systems
and I was interested in seeing what
happens when they go and study quantum
systems or very small systems and you
ask well do the same laws apply to
quantum systems or do we need to make
some Corrections and are these
corrections because of the quantum part
or just because we have very small
systems and there's some finite size
effect oh and are there like some new
quantum effects that we can explore it
and fry
in terms of thermodynamics so can we
expand this framework in this sense but
all of these people they still start
from this idea of it's not from
thermodynamics and now we want to
exploit it in II regimes on the other
hand you can have the engineer who is
someone who is interested in actually
developing a machine and making it
efficient according to some parameters
of of relevant in this regime and by the
way this is these are the kind of people
who develop the first thermodynamics
thermodynamics theory so here you might
be interested in very in very concrete
questions like or what's the heat
dissipation in quantum computers how can
we keep this law or you know how small
can you make heat engines and you know
maybe working Heat are not real the
available quantities to talk about but
we should be looking at different
parameters and what should I be looking
at ok so in this talk I hope that I will
go over a bit of the three of the three
perspectives so we'll have three parts
so in the first part we'll talk mostly
about the relation between information
in thermodynamics work cost of of
erasure or the work value of information
etc so we look first at the classical
case to give you some intuition and then
we look into the quantum case and then
so this will give us a bit of small
results and interesting phenomena but
not an overarching framework to treat
them and this is what you'll see in the
second part of the talk ok so there we
we look at axiomatic approaches to
quantum thermodynamics in particular
resource theory approaches we'll see
what they can tell us we'll see why this
particular resort theory are these
principles justified and then we'll talk
about directions and open questions ok
so you might think that a priori
thermodynamics didn't have anything to
do with information right you're trying
to move trends what does it matter what
information you have about the system
and maybe the first example where they
started to pray play a role was
Maxwell's demon so most of you are
already familiar with this paradox so
imagine a T of a box and it's filled
some guys okay and here's some observer
Alice and though she can't see off the
guys is that it has some pressure and
volume and it's all at the same
temperature okay so she cannot do
anything with this box but then we have
someone else who has access to more
information so this is a demon and yes
some microscope and you can see all the
particles in there and you know a gas at
a certain temperature because it's it's
formed by particles that are traveling
faster and slower okay with some
distribution and she's sitting here in
this little door and you can see which
particles go fast and which go slow so
he can control this door okay this
doesn't cost anything he just opens the
flap and it lets all the slow ones come
to the left and all the fast ones stay
on the right and with this what he
creates is like a gradient in
temperature in which he has like all
this cold gas on the left and a hot gas
on the right and then larrikin lets the
hot gas expand and extract some word
from this okay and for for many years
this was a puzzle of you know
thermodynamics tells us that you cannot
extract any work from a single heat bath
so how come that he can do this and
obviously the answer has to do with
information so let's see how to treat
this despite this okay no let's not see
how to treat this piece by piece let's
first think about the general question
of you know this is a nice paradox but
what about concrete applications for us
so the idea is that thermodynamics
studies is a kind of glorified
accounting of heat flows and energy
flows which is relevant because you may
have you may want to perform a
computation but you're also interested
in not just in the logical circuits that
you have but also in how much power you
have to supply to this computer or how
much heat will be dissipated also
because the heat that is dissipated my
my quasi decoherence problems and these
are the kind of questions that funnily
enough also have to do it if formation
also have to do with Ramona
makes and will also be addressed in
falling okay so see alright boxes are a
very simple toys model invented by and
here's the idea you have one bit of
information which is encoded in the
following you have a box with a
partition in the middle and then you
have a particle on one of the two sides
and around this box you have a heat bath
so some environment of some temperature
that keeps the book the particle with
some momentum okay if you don't like the
idea of a single particle heat bath then
you could think that all the gas
particles there's many gas particles on
the right or they're on the right but
they all on the left in other case you
have one bit of information
okay in the end he would be like how can
you extract work from this one bit of
information well if I know where the
particle is I can attach like a little
bucket with some mass and then this is
expanding so it expands this volume and
if I integrate how much it expands it
gives me actually KT log to work okay so
this is the difference in in the
potential energy of this thing okay so I
now have a mass that is high up and I
can use this as stored work okay so it's
like the classical idea of what work is
okay and we can also go the other way
around so imagine that I have this box
and I don't know if the particle is on
the left or on the right but I want to
reset this bit okay so I start with no
information what I can do is instead of
putting this lever this divider here in
the middle I can put it on one of the
sides and then just push it and pushing
this cost me again
KT log - ok is the Boltzmann constant so
it's just a constant to transfer to
compare between temperatures and energy
okay so this is the this the heart of
Lenore's principle which tells you that
well you can trade information and heat
from a heat bath for work so heat just
means energy that
we don't have very good control of and
like a heat bath and work just means
energy that we know why it is okay like
here you have this way that is left it
here so this is really no surprise and
what is interesting is this right this
conversion rate of KT log two per bit
and this by the way is the solution to
Maxwell's demon problem
so here's Maxwell's emoney already
created this this difference in
temperature between the two books the
two sides of the box you know this and
now you think oh he's done he just
extracted work from nothing but if you
look at a bigger system where you also
think about the memory of the demon then
this demon here to store his information
somewhere about each particle and then
either he will just you know never erase
this memory and then you have this side
product which is a new system filled
with trash that is useless now okay so
it's not a cyclic process or at some
point you will have to erase all of this
data and actually the the erasure of
this data so resetting this this
blackboard costs in exactly the same
amount of work that he spent that he
gained in this whole process in our back
to our other questions about the cost of
computations so the solution also has to
do with this trade-off between
information and and work so the idea for
balance is that every computation can be
split into two parts
won't it be a reversible part followed
by erasure so in the same way that when
you have con to map you can always die
light it to think of it as some unitary
followed by a unitary on on a system and
the unsealer falling by tracing out this
and silla okay forget thing about this
and silla and the idea is that let's
pretend for now that the reversible
computations are free in principle okay
and then the work cost becomes just the
cost of erasure of this extra and silla
because otherwise you end up
all these memories in your computer that
are full with useless stuff okay so what
do I need what do I mean by AirAsia more
explicitly it should be like formatting
a hard drive so this means I'd all this
business I sort is somewhat a zero
someone some I don't remember anymore
what they are and I want to set them all
to zero or in the case of a quantum
system I have some some system that
could be in some setting I want or is it
reset it to a standard state so just to
give you some idea of the numbers of
what this limit gives you so this
constant K is very very small such as
the erasure of a 16 terabyte hard drive
at room temperature cause 0.4 microtools
and to have some idea of what this means
lifting a tomato a tomato by one meter
on earth cost one Joule okay so this
fundamental limits are still very very
far from what the industry can do but
they will become relevant at some point
and they are interesting on their own so
now you could think okay so this cost me
KT log two per bit but what if I have
some more information about the thing
that I want to erase so for example you
could have a fractal a fractal is a very
looks like a very complex object and if
you didn't know that this was generated
by a small program you'd think oh well
why any tier 8 is all this okay
but since there is a very small program
that generates it what you can do is
compress okay like in the same way that
in coding theory you can code something
and then decode it so here you compress
it and this is a reversible process
because you can also go from that back
and now you have a much shorter program
and bits a which you then can erase so
then in the end this just costs you
NK 2 log 2 and the idea of this is that
in general what we can do is take any
message compress it and on the idea
limit this will give you the entry
of the of the original message and then
from this here is it and this is where
information comes into play
and another aspect of this is that well
information is also subjective so in the
same way that maybe someone before who
did not have information about this
fractal whatever harder time erasing it
you could also think that well maybe I
have a system and I prepared to him in
this bit one ok and then I tell Alice
Alice it's in it's in state 1 and I tell
Bob well I don't tell them anything ok
and then I tell them fizzy racist
okay so while Alice if she knows that
it's in state 1 she can just apply a
reversible operation like a not gate and
erase it for free now Bob would have to
apply a this iteration procedure which
then costs them KT log 2 which is to say
that actually the work coast of evasion
depends on the entropy and the entropy
you have to take into account the memory
of your agent this is the general result
in the classical case ok and now you may
think well okay how does this generalize
for the quantum case what needs to
change first of all I showed you of a I
mean a very almost microscopic szilárd
box and is there such an equivalent for
quantum systems or what does work even
mainland and then this idea of size is
inside information is very nice but how
do use a quantum memory you cannot just
read it because this would disturb the
contents of the memory and finally well
if you have quantum correlations and
this conditional entropy can be negative
and does it mean anything or is it just
you know just a quantity that is useful
for information processing tasks but
doesn't have a thermodynamic value or
meaning so I'm going to give you
this is a slow introduction to what
we'll talk about later so I'll give you
first two models for like this quantum
skillet books and the first one is a
semi classical model where the
assumptions are that well we have a work
storage system somewhere but for now
this is just implicit
and what we say is that well we have
some systems and we can live you can
change the Hamiltonian of the system and
to account for energy what we say is if
you lift a level by Delta e this cos
Delta e but only if the level is
occupied okay in the same sense that if
I if I lift a box this only costs me
energy if the box is full and vice versa
and reversibly also I can lower the box
and it goes Delta e if it's a it gives
me Delta if it's occupied so here's how
you extract work from one bit of
information so take a qubit here are the
two states 0 & 1
fortunately degenerate so now what
you're gonna do is you're first you live
this level very high and it costs you
nothing according to this model ok we'll
discuss the assumptions behind the model
later on so you lift you lift one very
high the state is not occupied you know
this so it doesn't cost you anything and
now you connect it to a heat bath and
the assumption here is that when you
connect it to a heat bath and you wait
long enough this goes to a Gib stage to
a thermal set so it's just an
exponential stay yes and you start
lowering this very very very slowly so
what happens in the beginning not much
happens because this state is not
occupied but as it lowers the
probability of being occupied gets
higher right so it's some probability of
getting Delta e every time you do this
and if then you integrate how much you
gained by the time you get to the end
you gain exactly K till or two on
average and you end up with
with a maximally mixed cubit this so
this would be one example of how could
ever quantum silard box if you believe
that these assumptions are justified yep
so here's another one tries to be a bit
more explicit and we'll come back to
this framework later so here you model
first of all you model your battery your
battery system explicitly so just like
before you thought of this way that you
lived now you can think that you have
our Monique oscillator okay and lifting
the state of this harmonic oscillator
corresponds to heat okay because now we
have a site in some in some high energy
state with some high energy which later
you know you can just store it there
like you store this way and then later
on you can use this that's the idea and
then for the heat bath well instead of
being always sermonizing my system I
just give myself an explicit heat bath
which I say it can be as big as it is
and it's already not in this gift stage
okay which means that I can take I can
draw qubits from there and you know if
the gap is very big then this
exponential mean that there's almost no
probability of being in an excited state
and if it's as it becomes smaller and
smaller the gap and the probably become
closer and then and then I say okay so
let's give myself these two things in
all the rules of the game is that I can
apply unit areas but only unit areas
that conserve energy okay so then I know
that I'm not injecting any energy into
the system and I'm not injecting or
taking away any any entropy yes are
these rules clear if you have questions
I might not see your hands so just say
something okay
so using this using this idea and
starting again from a qubit that is on
state zero there is a protocol which
which takes you to maximally makes qubit
here and in
and at the same time raises your raises
your your work storage system your
battery by catalog - on average with
fluctuations that decay with one over
square root of n where n is the number
of steps that you take okay so the idea
here is just like before in this in this
other semi-classical protocol you have
to do every step very slowly yes unless
things sterilize and move just a little
bit like going this quasi-static because
a static regime where the idea is you're
not throwing away too much energy at
every given step to the bath so here
what you do is you take many many many
of these qubits such that the
probability distribution here matches
almost exactly the probability
distribution here okay and you apply
essentially kind of a control swap where
you so where this access your control
qubit and you swap this - yes so what
happens then is on the first step with
very low probability it goes very high
and with most probably if nothing
happens in the second step the probably
of going up was a bit it's a bit higher
a bit higher a bit higher etc just like
before like when you start here and
there's a big gap very likely nothing
happens and as you go down the
probability that you gain energy
increases so the protocols are very
similar but the models are different
this okay so and vice-versa I can also
go from a fully mixed stage in your
system and you raise it to a state zero
and this costs you an average KT log -
okay so this is what we're going to take
as a building block like we took the
seal out boxes as a building look and
now if you have this then we can talk
about eurasia with quantum information
and then as I said before we cannot just
go look at the memory see what it says
and then do like a control operation
because we need we don't want to disturb
the memory too much so for example
imagine that you have all these qubits
in your in your lab and you want to
erase the first qubit but preserve the
sight of the others yes so for example
here your first qubit is your system
that you want to your race and it's
maximally entangled with the first qubit
of your memory if the other two are in
some stage and what you want to do is to
erase this first qubit so take it to
state zero yes and keep the rest as it
was so in this case it goes to row two
three doesn't change and this also
doesn't change so it's not a Maxima
mixed it and more general more generally
we can have this memory preservation
condition which means well I want to
raise s and I have access to some memory
M okay and my condition is that I don't
want to destroy em and I also don't just
want to destroy any correlations that M
might have with any other system any
other reference system yes so I want to
go to this state 0 and s and preserve
the rest good but I can act on em I just
need to return it in in the same state
and the the good result is that we can
still use this memory optimally like we
could in the classical stage so again
the workhorse of arisia becomes the
conditional entropy which now can be
negative so what does this mean let's
let's look at this simple example and
see how one could do it ok so we start
with this stage and the entropy of s
given M is minus 1 right because we have
here a pure state - the maximally - the
entropy of half of it which is a maximum
is qubits it gives you minus 1
and we want to take it to this stage so
here's a protocol to do it
on the first step we say well I have
here a very nice entangled stage I'm
just gonna use my building block like
this he'll add engine kind of protocol
to extract work from it okay so I can
unit i early take it to zero zero and
then I have two qubits in zero and I
take KT log two from each of them this
gives me two KT log two and you can ask
is this okay yeah it's okay because now
here on the one you have a Mac so mixed
eight which you already had before so
you did not disturb the memory indeed
you don't touch the rest of the memory
either and then on the second step you
just say well now I have a maximally mix
qubit here on the first so I use again
the building block and this cost me KT
log log two to raise so in total the
work cost was minus KT log two which is
precisely the entropy so again I did
this trade-off between information and
work I had these quantum correlations
before that I don't have any more yes
but in exchange again again some energy
okay and then more generally we can use
decoupling results and single shot
protocols and get something like that
looks sort of like this so the idea is
always sorry daddy is always the same so
look for some part of your memory that
looks maximally mixed or compress it to
look maximally mixed then erase that
together with the system you get work
out of this sorry extract extract work
from this and the system because it's
maximally entangled with the system and
then just see raise the system okay
so this was all about erasing a
particular state and now can ask well
maybe if I want to build a quantum
computer what I want to know is not so
much how much it costs to to treat a
particular state but how much it costs
to implement a certain gate so an
operation and that is very similar again
so the result there is that you if you
have a map that goes from X to X Prime
you dilated and then in the end the word
costs it's kind of the work it would be
the work of erasing this unzila that you
want to discard at the end right so it's
like your map goes in each I relate to
your final output system and Alan Silla
this doesn't cost any work but then you
want to erase the until and what else do
you have
well all I have here is my is this
output state ok so I use this
conditional entropy of the final state
ok and this has been generalized not
only for the generate hamiltonians but
for any Hamiltonian sinful advice thesis
and in numbers again it's a bit pathetic
because then running a 20 petaflop
computation costs you 1 watt okay so can
we are very very far from the from any
irrelevant we made which is good it
means that engineers he'll have a long
way to go before we need to do more
serious ok so again like these are all
results in very specific settings and
later on I want to generalize this whole
approach but before this let's let's
just go back almost a century and
something that I didn't know until a
couple of years ago is that you know
when I'm an entropy is called entropy
for a reason
and for thermodynamic reason okay so the
way he came up with this was thinking
well I have this I have a particle gas
and all my particles are in this quantum
state and they have n of them okay and I
want to erase this so meaning that I
want to take them to being all in the
same state yes and how can I come up
with a protocol that does this and what
she did was thinking well okay let's
apply here some semi permeable membranes
okay that only lets some of the
particles pass and I use this to to
separate them but there is no change in
volume for each of these particles for
each of this boxes so this doesn't cost
me any work so now I have here this this
three boxes and I know I know which
particle isn't in each of them so for
each of them I can oh oh no not yet okay
let's row and I'll apply a unitary but
before this I want to go back to my
original volume yes
of having just the small books and the
idea is that well okay so then the
volume in the number of particles in
each box will be proportional to this PK
okay so then so will the volume of the
final box and then it sees how much it
costs them to read to compress each of
these boxes and that is N and the
logarithm of the difference between the
volumes okay which is precisely n PK log
PK and I think well then let's do this
for all of them let's divide by the
number of particles and it gives me the
work cost of doing this operation which
is precisely the funnyman entropy and
then I can apply a unitary operation on
each of them
on each of these particles to to take it
to the side that I wanted or you could
have done it the other way around right
could have applied this its operation
here now I want to compress okay how
much time do I have now good so so now
let's try to get a bigger perspective so
let's think about why thermodynamics is
so effective in the first place so that
less you can find the right way to look
at it so thermodynamics is great because
it doesn't care about the microscopic
details of some theory it doesn't care
if your gas is made of quantum particles
or classical ones okay and that's why I
could survive this the advent of quantum
mechanics so what it does is it just
identifies what are the easy operations
for an agent to do what are the hard
operations what the resources that come
for free like the room temperature and
based on this it tries to tell you how
you can how you can exploit like these
conditions these constraints that you
have in order to build efficient things
like steam engines fridges also tries to
find like what's the minimal cost of
transforming one state into the other
and in that sense it's a very
operational approach and it's what we
call a resort theory and we could say
that this is the first resource theory
in physics so if you haven't heard this
term before then you probably heard of
LOC C and this is an example of a
resource T I'll go into this right soon
so just to give you an overview or
introduction to the idea so a resort
series to treat some kind of physical
situation or doesn't need to be a
physical situation as a game okay so the
idea is you you imagine that there's an
agent in this game and you're going to
play from the point of view of the agent
okay so it's say well here's my state in
my space of resources it could be
anything and here's some set of allowed
operations that I can do
and this imposes some kind of order in
the resources so for example I don't
know so this could be a way it's
standing here and a bit lower down down
but to the left and then it's a very
bottom for example yes
and there's only some directions which I
can go and so forth from this I get a
pre order in my structure okay which
gives me a structure and then from here
I can ask lots of questions so for
example maybe this is a very complicated
structure and I can ask is there a
simple way to characterize it can I find
for example monotone yeah something that
always goes down so for example here it
could be the height of the object here
or in thermodynamics you see that it
gives us the free energies and then you
can also ask well what are necessary and
sufficient conditions to go from one
resource to the other and what are very
useful resources in this area what are
useless resources I said for example
here this D resource is almost for free
because you can always get to it so for
example you know ACC LLC see your set of
other operations is something that is
deemed easy comparatively easy let's say
which are in this case local operations
and classical communication that's
because you think that you have agents
they are far apart and they can do
everything in their labs but they cannot
apply like global quantum si so if it's
always the set of operations that gives
this meaning to your resource theory
that justifies it and then the monotones
then you can get things like squashed
entanglement entanglement or formation
entanglement of distillation you learn
from here that separable states are
always free because you can always you
can always prepare them doesn't matter
what the initial state is and then you
can even think of things like a currency
which are states that are very useful
and scalable like pairs of bells days
how would you apply this kind of
thinking to thermal NMX here we go
so first of all let's think about what's
our limitations and let's think about
the classical case so one could be lack
of knowledge about my the exact state of
my system right when people are
describing systems in terms of volume or
temperature they didn't think that this
is the fundamental theory but it's just
the accessible information to them yes
so you can represent your sites like
this then your you are restrained by
conservation zones like energy
conservation momentum conservation etc
also limited control of operations you
you know might not have absolute time
control but just let some some guys
expand its kind of things so then you
think of this and what I resource is yes
this microscopic descriptions of systems
and their operations could be depending
on the settings they could be adiabatic
operations or isothermal operations
meaning that you have access to some to
some environment temperature for example
and then what insights can you get from
this kind of a framework well actually
just from treating it as a resource here
like this you can derive all the laws of
thermodynamics you write the free energy
as a monotone you derive the Carnot
efficiency as a limit to divisions of
eat engines etc and there is great work
on this by karate Lori and and Kyle's
and then later by a Libyan English one
in which they they just say well let's
have a theory and let's say that there's
something called equilibrium states
which are scalable which have this nice
order like in terms like in LOC CFL
pairs that you know you can always go
from 4 Bell players to 3 so they they're
ordered and then just using just using
this and little more than you can derive
things like like the free energy or the
entropy that's the only monotones at
scale nicely
and so how would you translate this to
the quantum case well let's think of
resources now as descriptions of quantum
systems and quantum descriptions of
quantum systems so this meaning I can
describe a system by some states and the
Hamiltonian of the system because these
are the things that we care about at the
moment and then what are the allowed
operations it's like in this model that
we saw before so we want to account for
entropy so we only allow for unitary we
don't let anything
give or take any entropy but also we
want to account for and all the energy
flows so I said all the unitary sets are
free are the ones that commute with the
Hamiltonian so the ones that don't bring
in any energy and then and then you can
start from this from this basic
framework and then add more things or
play with it
so one thing that is very common is to
then say well let's add a free
environment let's add some states that
free entity can always get so for
example we imagine that you you're doing
this experiment in some movement some
temperatures you can always set things
thermalize at a certain temperature yes
so is this and then of course the can
always trace out systems can always
forget yes of course that this is a toy
model right this is if there's ever been
a spherical cow thermal operations is it
okay and later on we'll talk a little
bit more about how to try to make this
more realistic so before I go into what
results you can draw from here let's try
to question a little bit more like why
should we allow for this environment for
free like why why do we model a heat but
as a as a thermal state ok and we do
this not only in in when it treats
thermodynamics like this but also for
example when you're modeling some
quantum memory and you want to have a
nice model this is useful more often
model as a thermal noise which is model
in term by a gibbsite so why why this
and is this justified so let's go by
parts I'll give you three justifications
to it
so the first one is that it's a reduced
description of a subsystem
if you take the set of maximum entropy
in the bigger system so what I mean by
this is suppose that you have a large
system composed of many independent
parts yes and then you know something
about the system for example you know
the total energy yeah and you know that
under thermal operations you're never
gonna change this energy so you're
always inside this shell and then assume
that this is all you know about that
system is the energy you know nothing
else okay any more of this because you
because you like probabilities you model
this as a maximally mixed state on this
one is energy shell ok then it's no
surprise that if you look a very small
system yes they need to look like this
exponential it looks like a gift stage
so this is kind of change principle idea
so if you take a very large system and
you have maximum ignorant any model this
via oh also its are equally likely then
you get a reduced description of of this
type okay so this is one way of saying
well we model it like a keep said
because you know nothing about this path
the other justification is that it's a
very typical stage actually and this is
it's not surprising if you're familiar
with the coupling results for example so
the idea here is well if you have a big
system and your small subsystem is much
smaller than for most global States and
most subsystems it will look as if it's
in a if it's it's in a gift state and
okay so the thing is you don't believe
that the big system is actually a micro
mixed it could be in any state but if
you apply some random evolution or if
you choose your subsystem randomly or if
you said if you choose it according to
some constraints then you very likely
get I give state here and one thing that
is important is that this is also true
if your subsystem is not a local thing
but it corresponds to just some degrees
of freedom that you you have access to
yes so the idea is that most observables
will appear to thermalize under this
under any bush yes so here's a picture
you have a big thing if a big system you
look at only a small subsystem and even
if you have some site information about
the whole thing
if you just choose the subsystem
randomly or apply a random unitary then
it will appear to thermalize there's
also dynamic thermalization results
which tell you that well if your
hamiltonian is rich enough which means
there are small perturbations and for
most times T and for most initial stage
then it will appear to thermalize okay
this for most time T the results on time
scale on time exact time scales vary a
lot and I recommend this very nice
review by Google in I said when you talk
about very different types of
thermalization and their different
constraints and also for concrete
systems okay so the last
[Music]
the last justification is this idea of
passivity of the thermostat so here the
idea would be well let's say we don't
give the thermostat for free we just
give this unitary operations so then
what is the the only stage that you
could always give that does not
trivialize the resource theory which
means suppose I just allow for unitary
and allow you many copies of the stage
yes
what is the only state that you could
not use to buy playing a unitary reduce
the energy of this state and raise some
weight
yes and the idea is that well if you
have only one copy of the set then any
state that has probability is decreasing
in on the eigenvalues will do yes but if
you have if you have many copies of the
state then only this exponential
distribution will do yes now despite all
this nice argument we know that the gift
set is still very coca yes it's still
like for example in all of these cases
say we know that we know that the state
of the system is approximately the gibb
state okay but it doesn't mean that it
is the gift stage but we model it like
the gift state because it doesn't hurt
because it doesn't give you anything for
free but it would be more interesting is
is to is to have a resource here where
you can model the heat bath as something
that you have less information about
them being in a good state and we'll go
into this a bit later on so I think
maybe I stopped the first part here
because then in the second part we can
go into results so it's a other
questions at this stage great yeah if
there's any questions please
I have a question about the claim you
made that if we choose sort of a random
evolution on a large subsystem then we
accept small subsystems of it to look
like thermal States is am i stating that
correctly yes that preserves energy I
see I'm just a little bit confused
because I've also sort of learned to
think of the fact that if I pick a sort
of random evolution with some disorder
in it then I should expect to get like
Anderson localization which prevents
thermalization so how should I make
sense of those two facts
so they're looking at where concrete so
when you say your evolution is random
how random is it's really
this should be my guess but okay I'm not
100% sure that this is a reason but it
should be my guess is it's like you know
all this all this results on on therm
well I mean it's very easy to Trevor is
also on typicality of thermalization
wanted to say taking over space I random
and and when you try to go to more
concrete measures for example I try to
replace the hard measure with something
more more physical than then it becomes
more complicated so for example for
there there are these results in this if
you have random local random but local
interactions that is still that
thermalization but I think has imposed
more constraints it becomes more and
more difficult to to get this and then
you need to go and study this was not my
mathematical physicists to then go and
study concrete systems and see what
happens any other questions you said we
are using the protocol of unitary
operators commuting with the global
minced onion to the operation desk do
not inject energy in the system yes of
course if you want to actually implement
one of the special physical system you
cannot do this immediately but you will
have to change temporal idiom Estonian
and wait that the unitary has been
applied and then Tony into what was why
when you train the amazonian you
actually have to inject energy in the
system yes and then you will need
something energy then yes we say maybe
they will be back at the end yes I mean
this is the point I was going to make in
the second part yes but go on yes the
question was that yes you have a frame
working where you can account exactly
for all this other machinery in order to
apply this we will look into this in the
second part I mean it's the idea of like
this is this very Coco right
and this already imposes some
restrictions but then later on we want
to impose more restrictions to make more
physical so for example do not allow for
this arbitrary control because as you
say you need to be controlling like when
you turn on and off a Hamiltonian and of
course that is cost something and we
will go into this later on yes all right
any further questions all right I guess
the audience has voted themselves a
longer coffee break
[Applause]